les dentistes qui refusent qu'ils
refusaient malades sur le sida les
ambulanciers qui refuse qu'ils refusent
est malade tu deviens un pestiféré en
quelque sorte les séropositifs victimes
de discriminations médicale dans les
années 80 90 le monde découvre les
ravages du sida
la panique gagne alors le personnel
hospitalier certains soignants host à
peine approcher les malades par crainte
que le virus ne leur saute au visage
c'est vrai que par exemple chez nous
quand on repasse un scanner sont des
gens qui passeront en dernier à leiria
deroff par exemple comme ça les
ambulances ont été désinfectés
ce sera le dernier le dernier est repris
dans ce climat de peur de mauvaises
informations sur la maladie alimente les
discriminations envers les séropositifs
parmi les mensonges colportés il y avait
ceux du président du front national de
l'époque jean-marie le pen mais aussi
daiichi où les emploie ce mot là est
contagieux par sa transpiration ses
larmes ça salit de gens ont tari jeu
qu'il est une espèce de l'épreuve pour
combattre ce rejet des victimes du sida
l'association aides voit le jour en 1984
en plus de l'accompagnement des malades
elle en forme est aussi le personnel
soignant sur le vih et nous serions
évidemment le fond de médecins nous
recevons des appels d'infirmières qui
sont dans de grands services
hospitaliers qui nous appellent le soir
en disant écoutez on est un ferment
aujourd'hui dans l'hôpital l'infirmière
qui m'a fait le pansement soigne des
malades atteints du sida qu'est ce que
je risque alors ça donne une idée un
petit peu de la circulation de
l'information dans les hôpitaux dans le
corps médical et dans le corps social
aide multiplie alors les campagnes
d'information
mais les préjugés sur le sida ont la vie
dure
cette exclusion médical ceux
séropositifs disait toujours la vivre en
il accusait son dentiste de ne pas
l'avoir soigné à cause de sa maladie il
a brisé quelque chose en moi donc ça en
bouleau 18 ans sur moi par rapport à ma
séropositivité qu'est parti comme ça une
discrimination qui existent jusque dans
la mort
en 2014 les personnes séropositives
décédées ne pouvait toujours pas
recevoir de soins funéraire
aujourd'hui en 2014 quand vous mourrez
du sida ou en tout cas quand un médecin
mais sur le certificat médical
séropositifs sida ou l'hépatite
immédiatement vous met dans un cercueil
vos proches peuvent même pas vous voir
et vous n'avez pas le droit aux soins de
conservation
ça n'a aucun sens le sida c'est une
manie dit transmissibles c'est pas une
maladie contagieuse
il faudra attendre encore quatre ans
avant que la loi change
depuis le 1er janvier 2018 les soins
funéraires sont enfin accordés aux
séropositifs décédé
[Musique]